[Music]
Overlord is upon us originally rumored
to be a Cloverfield connected film and
the movie recently departed from this s
director stands strong as its own entity
there's a lot to unpack from overlord
including an incredible opener and final
battle and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down the things you need to
know about the movie's plot and ending
there will be heavy spoilers and this is
a film that deserves to be seen on the
big screen so you have been warned
with that out the way I'm definition and
I roon it so you don't have to okay so
the first question that you may have
when clicking this video is are there
any connections to the club a few the
universe at all unfortunately not and
it's difficult to even imagine how the
plot of this film would have tied into
the anthology series there is however an
abundance of gore supernatural elements
and some absolutely incredible moments
that more than make up for what could
have likely just been a quick cash grab
like the Cloverfield paradox the film
begins on d-day and we joined
paratroopers Ford boys and their
squadron as they begin the counter
invasion the group have been tasked with
destroying an enemy radio tower located
on top of a church after their plane is
shot down they must make their way to
the target on foot which is when they
run into French native Chloe Chloe leads
them to the village where she lives
which overlooks the church and the group
realized that it has been fortified into
a Nazi laboratory Chloe lives with her
and who looks and sounds like Darth
Vader with the mask off and her younger
brother Paul a Nazi officer named wofe
no visits the house and attempts to rape
Chloe which is stopped by Boise and Ford
they tie him up and voice goes to
investigate the church upon arrival he
realizes that the area is pulled
straight out of your worst wolfenstein
nightmare and is packed with body bags
severed heads and corpses in the lab at
Boise discovers a serum and notices a
doctor carrying out experiments on the
dead Boise manages to rescue a member of
his company called Roosevelt who's been
experimented on and the two escaped the
facility with the serum in hand back at
the house they questioned Ratner about
the serum who denies all knowledge of it
but
to wrangle three and kills one of the
squadron members
Boise uses the serum on the seemingly
dead soldier which reanimates him he
begins to mutate and then attempts to
murder the group but they fight back and
as usual bullets don't hurt him and the
only thing that does is destroying his
head like really destroying it like
smashing it into the ground anyway well
that explains that the serum is capable
of bringing the dead back to life and we
get the famous a thousand-year Reich
requires 1,000 year soldier's life it's
a great line that really hints to the
methods of the Nazis and their real-life
goals which is something that I'll get
into later in this video where the flees
the group takes Paul hostage and gets
half his face blown off in the escape by
this point in the audience and
characters are hit with the realization
that the radio tower is still
operational and the deadline for its
destruction is slowly drawing nearer
voice convinces for that they must
destroy it and rescue Paul at the same
time with Chloe they set off on their
mission for the underground which is
where they plant the bombs and set up
the tower for demolition
Chloe rescues Paul but Ford is attacked
by a mutated Wapner who is now near
invincible Lana has injected himself
with a serum in order to heal his wounds
but this has sent him insane and he now
believes that he's a god unable to beat
him and fatally wounded for injects
himself with a serum and the to battle
it out board with the help of Boise
manages to set off an explosion that
throws Wepner down the mine where the
serum was discovered before telling
Boise to leave him this is because the
serum is too deadly to be in either the
hands of the Allies or Nazis and it's
safer being buried in the rubble what
anna confirms this by crawling up out of
the pit it's more of the dead begin to
reanimate around him
Boise escapes setting off the bombs and
destroying the tower and dig site and a
hearing at the end of the movie Boise
lies and says that board planted the
bombs inside instead of out in order to
ensure the radio towers destruction and
that did
now boys doesn't mention anything about
the serum even when questioned in order
to keep the secret's safe Roosevelt who
was experimented on earlier in the movie
remarks that he's in really good shape
for what he's been through
personally I took this as the serum now
being out into the world
Roosevelt was connected to the serum and
therefore exposed to it though boysson
Ford believed that they buried the serum
in the rubble they linger on this moment
a little too long for me to believe that
it isn't a hint at what may come now
that the serum is in the hands of a US
soldier well I absolutely love about
Overlord is that it's not too detached
from the real-life Nazis overall goal
the political party were heavily into
the occult and Hitler was renowned for
sending out soldiers to investigate
myths and legends in order to discern if
there was any truth to them the Aryan
Superman which is what Hitler believed
to be a superior race was famously
something that he strived for in his
hideous racial cleansing agenda the
doctor carrying out the experiments has
ties to the real world Holocaust
overseer dr. Josef Mengele his
concentration camp doctor used the
experiments heavily on children and
people under his care to see if there
were any ways to improve mankind some of
these experiments included amputating
patients limbs without anaesthetic and
giving them blood coagulation pills in
order to stop the bleeding
to help discern whether this could work
with wounds in combat it really was a
horrendous time period that are things
been well fictionalized here there's a
lot more going on beneath the surface of
overlord and I highly recommend that you
look deeper into Nazi history if this is
piques your interest personally I really
enjoyed the film and think that it
definitely deserves all of the high
price that it's gay it's well short
choreographed and doesn't overstay its
welcome making for a fun ride from start
to finish so what are your thoughts on
overlord did you enjoy the film and you
wish that they tied into the Cloverfield
universe comment below and let me know
and if you enjoy this video then please
like it and check out my breakdown of
the leaked Avengers 4 trailer which will
be linked at the end of this video this
is a channel for people who are heavy
into horror so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]